honestly I thought I was excited before
but now I'm here I'm even more excited
and I feel like I'm just ready to go now
it's been so much build up and then now
I'm like it's basically here I feel like
the whole nation is is getting behind
you as well getting into the spirit and
enjoying what what Liverpool has to
offer have you felt that along the
journey as well no I I really have I
feel like the support has just has
actually been overwhelming I feel like
you know before I was announced before
the song was released you never you can
never quite guess how it's gonna go so
just seeing people enjoying the song and
just enjoying Eurovision it's just been
very very yeah I couldn't have asked for
like a better welcome really